the cultures around the country are
going to be quite a surprise for the
feminists putting aside anti-Semitism
let's say let's say again let's say
they're not anti-semites they're okay
with the Jews fine how do you think
it'll go for the chicks the Lesbos the
gay guys the bisexuals the woke haired
people or just anyone who is liberal in
nature if you bring these people in
here's Anne cter on Tim uh Tim Po's
podcast here's the more ter reality is
that all all the all the reporters that
we've talked to who've covered this said
it's mostly young women being raped by
the human traffickers it's not no it's
not condoms it's they they don't care
about any of that well that's back to
your point on the um Christian um
underlying of of our freedom and we are
the freest country in the world I mean
anyone who comes from any other country
any any immigrant to Finland makes it
less white it's a very very white
country any immigrant to America makes
it less free we are shockingly the
freest country in the world in so many
ways that other cultures do not
understand and one of the things that
our media as denesh says there is there
is an operation going it's it's I've
never seen so much Collective lying um
but um the rape cultures around the
country are going to be quite a surprise
for the feminists I mean let me just
tell you ladies you never had it so good
as with American you know she's laughing
as she says it but the rape culture
again put aside the Jews if you are a
woman if your mother is a woman uh if
your sister is a woman or extrapolate
that any which way you know how do you
know that rapes in Britain in Germany in
Sweden rapes are off the charts women
are afraid to walk alone in big cities
because they have imported these people
they have different views as it's as it
relates to women and minorities and
everything else if you pick PCT any of
these countries any of the Arab
countries how's it going for minorities
there basically are none how's it going
for religious minorities how's it going
for Christians forget the Jews how's it
going for Christians in all these
countries there are about 20 Coptic
Christians left in Egypt okay and Egypt
is a little more westernized let's say
than some of these other countries so we
all know this is true we all know it's
true and and it's only going to work or
or we're only going to stop it if we
acknowledge it right we know what's true
actually we're not afraid to tell our
friends what's true and help them wake
up and then we vote for good
people